[Music]
what did they teach you at university do
you spend three years studying real
estate
you say you learned about how to value
properties which is really important
skill
what else so there's a lot of legal
stuff
but law for me is very black and white
it goes in one year and out the other
it's it's hard learning at a university
with a lecturer standing up there
that learning environment is it's not
for me you know it's it's kind of really
standing there reading a script off a
board and
they also taught you how to be like an
estate agent and
lots of law stuff a little bit of
construction technology
how much did you spend on that
university course 30 grand
okay how does that compare and listen
you can be as brutally honest don't just
because i'm standing here
but how does that compare to the how
much did you invest in the academy
uh 10 grand so you invested 30 grand at
university
to learn about real estate which was
okay
maybe a bit boring but i don't know i
wasn't there then you wasted 10 grand to
go on the property investors academy of
samuel leeds
what what are the comparables and what
are the differences because i'm really
curious as i say tell me blunt tell me
honest
no well put it this way if i came here
in 2016 and if there was such thing as a
course as academy back then
i know for a fact if i started the
academy back then in 2016 i would be
ten times further than today than i am
right now
um but the academy it teaches you how to
invest in property
the the university teaches you how to
work for people basically
academy teaches you how to work for
yourself and how to make your money work
for you
universities how how to work for other
people so so the real estate university
is very much about how to get on the
corporate ladder
how to how to maybe be a good estate
agent you know
how to be a good estate agent agents
earn peanuts maybe be a rics valuer you
know
estate agents earn peanuts though yeah
yeah like i was an estate agent i was i
was earning 12 grand basically yeah
you know so okay okay so you've been
three years doing that
you then read bilo rent high where i was
like this is how it's done
um what happened so straight off the
baller entire
i actually went on to google funny
enough and i searched
cheapest properties in the uk where the
cheapest houses in the uk yeah
burnley popped up interesting apparently
popped up
i had no idea because bernie's quite a
hype right now i mean everyone's
craving burnley right now but um burnley
popped up
and i found out that there was a
university there
that recently started and that kind of
got my brain ticking you know i
thought you know i was a student i i
lived in an hmo what if
these students need to live in hmo let
me find a house near the university
so i looked on a night move found a
house five minutes walk away from the
university
and that that was just like a gold like
a
little gold mine right there i was like
oh i need to get that
you know so so you then decided you were
going to buy
a property yeah and do it as a hmr yeah
now if you'd have been on the academy at
that point i'd have probably said you
need to do 10 of them or
but you were very much the mindset let
me try the strategy i'll i'll do and see
if it works
and then maybe then consider doing
further training with samuel joining the
academy getting more houses
um how did that first property go tell
me the figures how much you buy it for
what's it renting for
so i actually i try to get a we try to
obviously get a mortgage on it i
couldn't get a mortgage so
i thought you know i've got to get this
this is amazing
so i had all my money from shares and
harvest that i had saved up
i bought it for 55 000 with help from my
parents helped help me out a bit with
that
um so that was a total purchase price
that was the total purchase price but it
wasn't bad neck
it was in bad neck terrible neck it's
three bed house
we wanted to convert it into five bit
hmos very spacious property
so got some contractors in and
we couldn't really get bridging finance
either so we had to
make plans i also had started my job at
this stage as well this is right after
university
so from the money from my job from help
with more help with my parents we
managed to
fix it up for 50 50 grand
as well so you spent 50 grand fixing it
up
55 grand buying it so in total you spent
105 grand
100 yeah about 100 and 708 with all the
legal fees
and etc sure so stamp duty legals fees
hundred and seven hundred and eight
about a hundred and seven hundred and
eight grand
great and how much is it worth now after
all that work 115 000
okay so you've added you've added a
little bit of value
not crazy so so that's great
now it's mortgageable so you can
refinance it
if you want to which i imagine you will
do
how much is it renting out for so
rentals right now it's it's
getting it's five bedrooms 400 pounds of
room uh it's got
it's got five bathrooms as well um so
400 pounds of room so i'm getting a two
grand turnover and then
profit out of that i'm getting about 900
pounds a month interesting
so so you're renting out for about two
thousand that sounds quite good for
burnley
yeah no it is who are you using as a
management company
uh e m property solutions okay i know
them
they're really cool team is a friend of
mine okay
so you're renting it for 2 000 pounds a
month and to students
uh no it's two actually the students
aren't doing so well at the moment so
it's actually to the
the boohoo factory workers at the moment
great covered
student but they're paying 2 000 a month
you're paying
and why your expenses so high why are
you paying over a thousand pounds when
you haven't even got a mortgage that
sounds really high
well that's that's going to be after
these figures or sorry
after after the mortgage right so once
you've refinanced it
great that makes sense that's on the go
right now right and once you've
refinanced
it after all maintenance management
mortgage everything yeah so the the
mortgage is on its way right now
and when you refinance it you're gonna
be able to pull out a considerable
amount of your money
yes which will be nice you can pay your
parents back and everything that's great
i'm gonna be paying parents back i'm
gonna be paying some bulldozers off
yeah yeah brilliant so now you're
running out and this that's exactly what
barlow rent high is
yeah exactly yeah someone said to me
just on tick tock actually
i said i was in ironically in burnley
um going around a little house and a guy
called pete
who um he's on samuel 365. bought a
house in bernalillo he's just he's just
about to rent it out and he's got it
advertised around about 1600 for a four
bed
right similar to yours 1600 for a four
bed
nice decent condition and people in the
comments were saying there's no
someone said my dad's a landlord there's
no way you'd get 1600 pounds
a month for a house that was bought for
66 grand
my dad has got a house that's worth 600
grand
and he gets the same rent so that it
can't be possible i'm like
that's the point the point is
you can buy a house for 600 grand and
rent it for 1600
or you can buy a house for 66 grand and
rent it out for 1600
with a bit of work and things and of
course you've got to pay bills so it's
not quite
like for like but but the point is one's
going to give you a return on investment
of about
four percent and one's going to give you
a return on investment of about
40 both are true